[Music]
i have a special treat for you all today
my dear friend and former college
roommate is here from the johnson space
center in houston to talk to us about
our space program
and yeah i know what you're thinking
these guys were roomies
how does one go on to be a a fancy
scientist at nasa
and the other's teaching freshman
science at a public high school
yeah sheldon i was thinking that
thank you all right
uh let's give a warm welcome to my good
buddy dr ronald
hodges hey kids hey glad to be here
and uh hubert the answer to your
question is one of those roomies was
busy studying while the other was out
chasing high school girls
yeah to be clear they were all over 18.
now what i thought would be fun to talk
about today is what nasa's planning on
doing beyond
the space shuttle things like the first
manned mission to mars
uh yeah did you see the movie aliens
i did did you think it was cool
uh sure i enjoyed it
me too yeah football player right
yes sir now
of course before we can set out to
explore the solar system
we've got a few minor problems to
overcome not the least of which is
every time we launch it costs the u.s
taxpayers hundreds of millions of
dollars
oh no no no yes if you want to save
money why don't you land the booster
rockets instead of letting them drop in
the ocean
that's a cute idea but it's not
technically possible
why not
well it's hard to explain the math is
pretty complicated perhaps i could help
you with it
i bet you good
i bet you could i tell you what here is
a
nasa patch why don't you have your mom
sew that on your book bag
now who here wants to know how
astronauts go to the bathroom
oh right see now during liftoff all the
astronauts
wear diapers people often wonder why i
chose to pursue a career in theoretical
physics
i usually respond by saying i wanted to
unravel the inner workings of the
universe
yeah perhaps when captain kirk said to
boldly go
he meant in one of those huh but the
real
answer was i wanted to prove this saw a
lawyer today
why i'm putting together my last will
and testament
we're gonna miss you george don't worry
i ain't leaving him squat
are you done we're all done honey from
the second we're born it's just to slip
and slide into the darkness
unless you get bit by a vampire well
now that goes without saying
i don't want to die i've only kissed one
boy so far
what relax it was a long time ago
are you relaxed shelly you haven't
touched your dinner
you feel okay oh yes i was just thinking
about what baby the optimal height to
width ratio for a reusable rocket
i was just thinking the exact same thing
really oh moon pi i love you so much
[Music]